this is Dana a German Shepherd with a
unique ability she's been trained to
sniff out mosquitos today she's showing
off her skills to a group of researchers
in Mali who are working hard to
eradicate malaria
Dana is helping them understand where
mosquitoes go in the dry season a large
swath of the African Sahel including
Mali is extremely dry for up to eight
months of the year when the rains began
in the spring mosquitoes suddenly appear
in huge numbers as if from nowhere it's
possible that the mosquitoes migrate but
entomologist Toby layman thinks that the
species that transmits malaria most
efficiently stays and hides Dana's job
is to find their hiding spots if the
researchers can figure out where
mosquitoes weighed out the dry season
they might be able to wipe out the
insects and the disease they carry when
they're easy targets
the problem is mosquitoes have no
natural scent for this unusual canine
collaboration to work the researchers
had to give mosquitoes and odor they
chose vetiver a grass that's not native
to Africa
it's oil has an earthy smell that's
pleasant enough to work with and lasts
long enough to use in experiments the
idea is to capture and anesthetize
mosquitoes
then glue vetiver scented strings onto
their bellies Dana
learned to recognize the vetiver scent
in California with trainer Sapir weiss
they've come to Mali to see if the
training has worked and it's going well
Dana's find is rewarded with a tennis
ball a favorite toy hmm the hunt
continues in and around a village
culture Ola to prove the concept works
dana is looking for scented strings that
have been hidden in natural holes molly
is much hotter than California and since
dogs can't sniff and pants at the same
time Sapir had to retrain Dana to stop
searching every so often so she could
Pantene
Dinah's work was so successful that
Sapir taught to more dogs and their
Malian handlers to continue Dana's worth
when she returned home the dogs have
turned up nine suspicious shelters
giving researchers clues about where
mosquitoes may hide potential hideouts
include holes in the ground old termite
mounds and small holes in big trees the
next step is using nets to try to catch
mosquitoes as they emerge from their
hiding spots when the rains begin thanks
to the noses of dogs like Dana
scientists are getting closer to their
goal of eradicating malaria